on amène ensuite
j
tu
[Musique]
je suis
l'idée c'était vraiment de proposer ce
ce plat avec le homard légèrement taillé
en salpicon c'est important finalement
que quand les astronautes vont goûter
ses plats que c'est soit des plats
qu'ils soient très savoureux avec
beaucoup de caractère
[Musique]
des aspects liés à la micropesanteur où
tout le monde se souvienne de la bulle
de whisky du capitaine haddock dans
tintin et donc si on a des aliments trop
liquide on risque d'avoir des bulles
comme ça qu'ils partent dans la station
et qui peuvent créer des problèmes pour
circuits avec des instruments etc
donc il faut qu'on ait des aliments il
n'ya pas il n'ya pas cellule ce liquide
qui peut se disperser
[Musique]
m
en ce matin nous avons effectué le
dressage le montage des bois et ensuite
les boîtes sont sertis donc c'est à dire
qu'elles sont fermées sont elles sont
elles deviennent étanche en fait grâce à
l'opération de ratissage et puis ensuite
elles sont stérilisés
[Musique]